so we start our first day of workshop
with was not left we talk about robots
possible variant situation
thank you very much Andrea and thank you
yes and we are the organizers of this
workshop some very interesting so far
I'll tell you about the joint work I did
with the jungles and good at the man who
is here somewhere in the audience and it
is about combining high dimensions
sparsity and robustness I'll be very
specific about what type of robustness
we mean here so the talk outline a brief
introduction about covariance matrix
estimation I'll then review some prior
work which essentially assumed this sub
graph sanity and then I'll present some
results when the data from an elliptical
distribution which may be heavy tails
okay so suppose we have a P dimensional
random variable and we observe data and
of course we know that in principle all
you wanted to know what X is found in
its density the problem is that we have
curse of dimensionality estimating F
would require nonparametric ly in
general would require an exponential
number of samples and therefore we
typically opt to compute simpler
quantities like the mean or the variance
or other quantities and and many
statistical tasks only need these lower
order moments so we have the mean we
have the covariance we have its
principal components which are the
leading eigen values and eigen vectors
of the covariance matrix and this is
widely used for many tasks for
dimensionality reduction visualization
denoising and regression classification
etc and of course if we observe data we
can compute we can replace the mean by
the sample mean the
with a simple covariance and we're
interested in principal components we do
an eigen decomposition of our sample
covariance matrix and use the estimated
eigenvectors are principal components
okay now in the good old days we had
datasets that had small dimension large
sample size also be asymptotic analysis
was done with prefix after size tends to
infinity and under various mild
conditions you get asymptotic
consistency of all of these quantities
and else behave actually there should be
a square here but it will behave like P
over N and again if P is small and n is
very large a we're doing fine but in
high dimensions a so P over N is not
small anymore
and in addition let's say if P over N is
louder than 1 you have more dimensions
than the sample size your covariance
matrix is not even invertible you incur
an L which is at least as large as the
smallest eigen value of Sigma is much
larger in general and one question that
has attracted the attention the
community is can we do better and those
pass the assumptions and for if we
assume that the mean factor is passed
this goes back to denying just one
anothers and there's a well understood a
theory about it this past normal means
problem for the covariance matrix both
Buckhannon Lavina and el Cucuy and and
many others around that time both
opposed models for sparse covariance
matrix and proposed very simple
algorithms essentially threshold thing
that will later show to prove some
modifications to achieve minimax
about of course there's also a lot of
interest on inverse covariance matrices
and the Peter Bowman and many others
have worked on this as well I'll not
talk about this I'll talk more about
this in this time so in particular many
prior works assume that a random
variable X has subduction tails and we
were interested in cases where X may may
be heavy tail and again the key
challenge that is I don't think it's
fully resolved is how to combine high
dimensional data with sparsity and with
robustness to heavy tails possibly also
to outliers of disgust it's a bit at the
end so what I'll do today is a discuss
sparse covers estimation and the a heavy
tail data that specifically comes from
an elliptical distribution and towards
the end of discuss a little bit if we
can relax these assumptions so again I
just got some Theory some algorithms and
there will be many open questions yet to
be addressed
ok so here's the model that was proposed
by beacon and levena and there was I
think a similar model bye-bye nobody NL
Korea as well we look at the covariance
matrix P by P and we assume it's
diagonal entries are bounded by some
number and that when you compute the lq
norm of each row it's bounded by some
other number SP which can grow in
principle with P and if Q is 0 then this
is the exact sparsity here 0 each row
has at most SP nonzero entries
and the main result is that if you start
from a sub Gaussian random variable P
dimensional that has zero mean and a
sparse covariance matrix here's a very
simple algorithm to try to estimate your
spouse population matrix you just
compute the sample covariance which
costs you a NP squared and you threshold
it which cost you all the P squared over
all entries and your threshold roughly
at this level and you're guaranteed
inspector law to have this hello and
later on Chi and you prove that this is
the minimax trait so you have a
procedure very very simple that achieves
the minimax rate you couldn't hope for
much much better now if you look at it
the result why does it work it relies on
a very simple deterministic lemma which
says the following that if you have a
sparse matrix B so here's our space of
matrices here's a matrix B and it's
approximately sparse and if I have some
other matrix a that is close to be in L
infinity norm it entry wise close to B
so here's my matrix a and a IJ minus bij
are smaller than some constant square
root of log n over P if you're able to
find such a matrix a then you can take a
threshold with a case larger than this
constant C and you're guaranteed to have
this result okay this is a little mini
circuit so there's no way random
variables here involved a and
so why does this work with subduction
yeah so just one clarification I take Q
equals 0 and P proportional to n is it
true that this is minimax or minimax up
to log factors weight the minimax is not
here the many much this is the this is
the result single take zero and is there
something hidden like a log P of error
you know and sorry really log P I think
it's quite a block P ever and I don't
remember if the result of kyon juror for
Q louder than zero equals zero exactly
okay all right now
so this is our target matrix we want to
get the matrix that entry wise is close
to it and the reason why with sub - and
data this is easy to do is simply that a
you just take the sample covariance
matrix with subduction data it satisfies
this inequality okay so this is
essentially I'm hiding all the no
trivial technical details but this is
the the crust of the proof in the paper
of a novena in other works and now the
question is what happens if we have
heavy tailed data so this lemma is still
correct
it's a mystic lemma but the sample
covariance matrix will not satisfy this
anymore so we have to find some other
way to get close to it
entry wise and so one question is lower
bounds how well can waste away this Fork
of s matrix if you have harita
distributions can we do it in a
computationally efficient way and I'll
show you some results where the data is
elliptically this
so what is an elliptical distribution
it's a very common distribution in
various fields in particular in in
signal processing and communications
that's the definition it has a mean mu
how do you generate an elliptical random
variable you start from a random vector
Etta uniformly distributed on the unit
sphere you you multiply it by the square
root of a shape covariance matrix to
definite and then you can scale it up
clearly
by a random variable U and U is what
gives you the heavy tail the phenomena
you can take if you take you to be
Cauchy then you have a random variable
that does not even have a well-defined
me okay
and a notice that this definition is not
unique right I can multiply my shape
matrix by 100 and divide you by 10 and
I'll get the same result so to have a
precise normalization of course I'm I'm
aiming to estimate the shape matrix SP
I'll assume it has trace of P which
essentially means that on average each
variable has before the scaling by you
whichever each variable has a variance
of one okay
all right so and up a so that's the
definition of a elliptical distribution
and if the random variable U is
sufficiently well behaved so that the
population covariance exists then it is
a constant multiple of the shaping
tricks okay and again if you're
interested later on in principal
component it out in principal components
then of course the principal components
of Sigma and of s are the same okay so
here's the question that we're going to
try to address I observe n samples from
a possibly heavy tailed elliptical
distribution and I want to actually
estimate its shake matrix SP I'm going
to assume that it's approximately sparse
and I want to do it in a computationally
efficient way okay so again the main
idea is that we're going to try to
construct some matrix as hat that would
be empty wise close to SP if we're able
to do that we apply the threshold thing
and we're guaranteed to get the enolate
that I had before okay so first of all
remember there is also this a mean mu
which I also don't know and I'm gonna
have heavy tails estimating it robustly
may also be challenging I think the next
talk maybe will tell us about that but I
just want to get rid of it without
needing to estimate it and there is a
very simple trick it's a symmetrization
trick if you have two random variables
that come from analytical distribution
with some mean mu just take their
difference it's still elliptical but it
now has mean 0 and it still has the
shape the same shape matrix so I'll just
look at n over 2 pairs X 2 I minus X 2 I
minus 1 and I'll recall I'm doing some
user notation that will be my n so I
I started from two n observations and
now I have n mean scented observations
and they're all elliptical zero mean and
shake matrix SP okay and this idea
appears in many papers one of them is by
Lutz Duncan there he considers all pairs
I'm I'm just taking n over two because I
don't want to have dependencies in my
analysis but in practice you can use all
pairs so from now on I'm going to assume
that mu equals zero okay so again my
goal here is my shape matrix SP and I
want to get to find an estimator that is
close to it
entry wise
okay so regardless of sparsity a about
thirty years ago they'd be Tyler
proposed an estimator for the shape
matrix of elliptical distributions and
it is the solution of this nonlinear a a
system of equations you have your
unknown is your matrix Sigma and it
appears on the right hand side and on
the left hand side and notice that
essentially you can think about this as
weights so so you have to put the
reduces solution etcetera but suppose
there is this a solution it's and it's
unique then the solution is essentially
a weighted covariance matrix okay
yeah at least the first three conditions
for some you know convex program or
something like this I'm just curious
so I'll discuss the computational
efficiency in a minute okay hey first of
all this matrix a this is a nonlinear
system of equations a does not have
unique solution you can you can scale a
Sigma by by any constant C and it will
still satisfy the the equation so so
that allele suggested the normalization
so the trace is one and can't entirely
pool if you do if you apply these
iterations they convert they put the
reduce unique solution the santo
assumptions and that if you apply these
iterations it would probably converge to
the unique solution they don't discuss
convex optimization
they just say do these iterations income
converge yeah that's the question it can
also be phrases is
family distributions for which this is
taxable activities yes so Thailand
pooled that a a tiles MS tomato is the
maximum likelihood estimator of your
shake matrix from an elliptical
distribution solution this is the
maximum likelihood estimator and you
sure that it's a robust estimate is
consistent for prefixed and goes to
infinity and so in principle it seems
that maybe I'd say that for a minute
AP is smaller than n then maybe
computing titled M estimator and Thresh
holding it may be a good candidate okay
unfortunately what tile is estimator
itself is not defined when P is larger
than n notice the equation on the left
hand side you have Sigma inverse but
you're summing at most n rank one
matrices so if n is smaller than P
there's no solution to this equation and
in the last ten years
several people many from Electrical
Engineering proposed a regularization
approach so without this term you would
have Tyler's M estimator they said let's
shrink to the identity okay and people
prove that a if you take a large enough
alpha then this equation does have
unique solution and this is called the
regularize tyler's M estimator people
show that it has so this equation that
does not necessarily equate any
normalization the unique solution for
any sufficiently large Alpha and it
satisfies the stress condition and also
I think both of these works which were
published roughly the same time pool
that again if you do these iterations
you will converge to the unique solution
yeah some [ __ ] results today tell you
a little too much this is I'm going to
address that in a minute no they they
just say no they they just prove that
the iterations converge they don't have
any rate okay this is exactly one of the
things I'm gonna discuss in a few slides
okay so so that so far was just a
studying the problem and a review of
previous works and now let me discuss
our results so again here is out a entry
wise thresholding operator and if we
have n larger than P then we can try to
compute either as M estimator and
special date I multiplied by P because
my shape matrix has a normalization the
trace is P and for any values of P n n I
can try to compute my regular lifestyle
L M estimator I'm going to remove the
regularization term I'll divide by the
trace of this matrix so I get a trace
one multiplied by P so I get the trace P
matrix and I'm going to threshold okay
so these are our two proposed estimators
and
they're able to prove is that this
indeed works for elliptical
distributions in an acid worst thing
about in asymptotic model where and grow
together and we have a sequence of shape
matrices of approximately sparse P over
N tends to a constant here the column
has to be smaller than 1 because then
this is what I lose I'm estimator then
doing this would give you the same
asymptotic error rate as the flesh
holding the sample covariance with
subduction data and we've discussed that
this is a mini much Freight optimal and
a similar result holds for a for the
regularized tiles M estimator that with
a sufficiently loud regularization
parameter you get the same rate here we
need an extra condition that the largest
eigen value of the shape matrix is
bounded by some absolute constant this
condition does not appear in a in with
subduction data and I don't know if it
can be removed I'll explain where it
comes from
ok so as we've discussed this estimators
a rate optimal okay so I will not
describe the proof but only a highlight
some concepts about the proof so in
general it relies on on recent results
of a geometric theory concentration of
measured cessation of quadratic forms
and a here are the key ideas so first of
all
let's go back to the definition of tiles
of regular light i little m estimator
yeah is the equation notice that this
estimator is invariant to scaling of
individual vectors right if I take an
observation X I multiplied by 100
nothing happens right you get 100
squared here you get a handle squared
here it would have the same effect a and
therefore instead of analyzing in
general elliptical distributions I can
assume that my underlying data is
Gaussian with this shape matrix the next
step is to write the regularized Tyler
MST mater as something times the
identity plus something else times a
weighted covariance matrix and the key
idea is to show that these weights where
the data is Gaussian that these weights
are very close to being constant right
there were all exactly some constant a
like R over N also value R then this
would be the sample covariance matrix
and then this explains why a method
works okay so the key technical part is
to prove this result that will Gaussian
data all of the weights even though you
have a highly nonlinear equation for the
tylium estimator all the weights are
tightly concentrated on some very value
are arranged yep weights depend themself
for Sigma so what you do into
that the concentration holds uniformly
excellent question
I have x1 up to xn they have weights W 1
up to W n all the weights WI are all
functions of all the X J's and on the
shape matrix SP yeah they are the
solution of the day of that highly
nonlinear equation okay and a the value
are the limiting value R is a function
of s P alpha well let's say P n n but a
synthetic elite it depends only on the
ratio P over N okay so that's right here
right okay and this is precisely where I
need that extra assumption that lambda
max of SP is lower than some absolute
constant s max because I need to wear
this our technique currently needs to
bound this R so it doesn't explode and
that it doesn't go to 0 and this extra
condition which is not present in works
that only assumed the subduction a data
a this condition ensures that these are
this limiting are remains bounded okay
that's how it works
okay so aim so that's this is
essentially the key technical part yeah
seems to some extent that that should
also be needed
at the end of the day you need to
guarantee that your you are in some
sense doing a fixed point iteration so
you need to have the Matis contracted
probably the 603 yes I'll show that the
I'll discuss in a minute how the fact
that you can compute Tyler as I'm
estimator in a condition efficient way
but a this is just tells you you goddess
what can you get to the limiting or to
the unique solution in the unique
solution the wait satisfy this
concentration of measure okay other
questions
so for Tyler semester mater we use the
result of a Zhang Sheng and singer from
two years ago and in their case we used
other than n and the limiting constant R
is just one so a double you guys are
roughly 1 over N and so with Gaussian
data Tigers M estimator is very close to
just the sample covariance matrix and
okay in well the regularize tme yes
yeah I'll use a function of alpha P or
an SP as a rotate mode a precisely I
need to show that L becomes bounded so
things don't blow up and this is where a
there are several pages of algebra that
need better needed to prove this and
since many people have asked me can you
compute this in polynomial time
so again previous works about either
team e or other you know I still me as
far as I know the result says start from
some initial matrix do these iterations
and you're proving to converge but they
don't give you a rate of convergence
what we were able to prove is the
following result so first you give me
data set and I'll compute this number
I'll compute this norm again it's ice
but office first paralyzing like my data
I am normalizing it and multiplying
everything by P or n so I'll compute
this matrix computing spectral norm and
[Music]
if you had it I mean what I'm going to
tell you about now there's not the same
elliptical data okay but if you had
elliptical data then this number would
be roughly 1 plus square root of P over
N squared this will be the largest eigen
value of a the edge of the matching
couple story
and here is dilemma that if you take a
regularization parameter large enough
rather than let's say five times this
quantity then you get linear convergence
rate with a factor of hats okay and you
can play you can change make this
smaller this will be slightly larger etc
so if you want accuracy epsilon but one
of our epsilon iterations we get you
there and each iteration you need to
invert a matrix so you can do that in
minimum between N and P cube populations
okay so I think this should answer your
questions earlier okay and another point
I want to make is that it's computing
this is practical on a PC just takes a
few seconds let's say for 4,000 by
thousand matrices or something like that
so I want to show you some simulation
results this is a here this is a matrix
at all suppose we could intervene ahead
in the paper I'm gonna take this is my
spar shape matrix and I'm gonna look at
three possibilities just Gaussian data
I'll take Laplace which is heavy tailed
but moments exist and not just and then
I'll take Koshi
and I'll look with verse value of P over
N and now we'll look at the sample
covariance Thresh holding the sample
covariance looking at the tme and then
thresholding the team okay and well
computer la as mean square devil
inspector Lohmann will would take a log
okay so this column is so each row is a
different a P over N and this column is
just Gaussian data and full Gaussian
data thresholding the sample covariance
or threshold in TM e essentially give
you the same result you don't see these
because they're exactly on top of these
a brass when once you have the plastic
oshi data
computing the sample covers and
thresholding it does not work but flash
holding the TM e gets you small errors a
as a function of sample size
all right now I looked at what happens
if I have a outliers or domination model
so suppose that 1 minus epsilon n of
your data comes from an elliptical
distribution with a special matrix s and
the other samples come from a different
different it's elliptical distribution
okay and I'll take two different models
for the outliers in the first one so the
outliers have a shake matrix D well and
then it's rotated so that it's it's a
nice bell-shaped matrix but a one model
is that the outlier are diffused
throughout the unit sphere and then the
other one the outliers are essentially
on a two dimensional subspace right
there are two directions where you know
P and P over to where were most of the
outliers live on ok all right
and so for example in the first example
s max of the outliers is bounded and in
the second one it increases with peak
alright so if so we have data in liars
and outliers if some of you were able to
distinguish the outliers we could remove
them and recompute everything in
threshold and what have we learned so
far if we had only in liars and we
compute the regular Einstein little M
estimator all the weights are very close
to some value R ok which we don't know
because we don't know the shape matrix
but we're now that tightly concentrated
around some value R and the hope is that
the outliers who have a different weight
if they have different weights then we
can easily distinguish that and this is
indeed at least imperfectly what happens
I sorted
my data so I had 500 points here I had
100 outliers and here I had 200 outliers
and as you see the in Liars had some
than you are the outliers haven't had a
different value bar and now it's very
easy to distinguish between the two I
just a compute a let's say nonparametric
this the estimation of the weights find
the mode take something around the mode
and then this is essentially so the blue
line is a non parametric estimation of
the mode and this is a band or I think
maybe one or two maybe two standard
deviations around the mode okay a so
here's where we have some open questions
and conjectures so one conjecture we
make is that asymptotically if you have
a mixture of inliers from an elliptical
distribution and out like from a
different one
you would have the weight would
concentrate on two values W in W out
well a different estimator that is
related work by a high and co-authors
now what happens in the yeah so this is
a simple procedure to try to detect the
outliers okay
and this is what you get as a result on
the x-axis is your outline ratio this is
your arrow without removing outliers and
this is a the arrow that you get after
our tiles have been detected and removed
and you get your breakdown at roughly
half which is where you don't you cannot
distinguish between the two
let's take the other case in the other
case the outliers were on a subspace
more or less of dimension to that
subspace had a manaat' satisfy this
condition it increases with P and what
you see here is that the outliers now
instead of being concentrated around
some weight other wait are they are all
over the place but that's fine I can
still compute the mode of all of these
weights a band around the mode and this
is what you're seeing here and you can
still remove most of the outliers of
course if some of the weights are in
this band they stay there and in this
case it seems that the breakdown point
is even better than half okay because I
don't have because these would even if I
had for you know 80% outliers they would
well I didn't yeah I actually I don't
see it here I didn't yeah even if you
have more than 50% outliers you would
still get a similar picture and it seems
that in this case you can do something
even better so again this is without
moving of outliers this is a yeah
perfect okay see to slide and indent all
right so some open questions first of
all a result of presentable theoretical
a the threshold you know I'm just saying
that even without I plus the threshold a
the statement says that there is
especially nice letters automatically
you'll get the the minimax rate how to
estimate the threshold in a data-driven
manner is an interesting question can
you do the analysis if P increases with
n at a higher rate than n like N squared
or some other increase illegal analysis
of an epsilon contamination model I
should mention here a work by chenggao
and then who's one of them is here at
least and they they analyzed a vs2
outliers using two peas depth function
which in general is computationally hard
and the question is is there a
completely efficient or practical robust
estimator for at least a certain class
of outliers with a
inliers being as a sub Gaussian or
something else
so to summarize and also maybe to
distinguish so if Ilya stopped and think
also Daniel about robustness to outliers
in high dimensions but sample size also
increases maybe even larger than the
dimensions there are cases where the
dimension is large the sample size is
limited and we want robustness in that
case as well and then we also need to
assume some sparsity so I think it's a
different regime which is also
interesting to look at ok
[Music]
what we've done is something in a way
limited but it's a first step how to
estimate a sparse covariance matrix
using heavy-tailed data I should mention
that in ongoing work a whatever what I
told you about holds for a much larger
class of underlying distributions you
can start from a random variable which
is not uniformly distributed on the unit
sphere it only needs to satisfy a
loksabha live inequality which is
slightly stronger than sub Gaussian but
then you can scale it similar to an
elliptical distribution everything I
told you we believe continues to hold
we're still working on this and again I
think an interesting question is is
there a perfectly computationally
efficient method that can handle I'll be
the outliers what type of outliers can
we handle a not only competition
efficiently but some here this practical
that has run time a it's a P squared or
P cubed or something along those lines a
another interesting question is if you
want to do sparse PCA or bus to outliers
interesting obvious papers on my website
our papers on the archive thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
so there is a paper by a group of an
infant from Preston that I think they
use candles approach it has some
parameters that they also need to tune
we use tiles because it's widely used in
various applications it seemed like a
natural candidate and it works some work
on the fact that you easily contacts so
you could try to optimize try to
estimate Sigma and I do
and you wouldn't have to do this
iteration so again as far as I know
these iterations are the way people
practically compute I the same estimator
and what we proved is that with
sufficiently large a regularization it's
it's strongly convex if you wish there
is a linear convergence threshold where
is there any hope of doing you know some
form of structural specification or
sketching sketching is something else
okay in sketching uuuuu subsample your
data or use something else it's you lose
information in that way / holding has
has been found to be universally a
excellent procedure to handle sparsity
once you get a nearby estimator if there
are sort of a very strong reason from
Fredette like for from an analytical
viewpoint like where you really feel
like you need to be interesting as
opposed to a software versus some other
foreign specification well any phone
specification would well you think of a
shrinkage that does not necessarily set
things to zero you can think about other
penalty terms that maybe will shrink in
a nonlinear way and not necessarily set
things to zero
okay Westar Bonecrusher Seguin how your
balance or depend on s-max
these whatever pound is found s-max and
then say yes exit I think so
the short answer is that okay the short
answer is that a this assumption implies
that there is no constant here that
depends on s-max
but remember it may seem
counterintuitive PN and PN n by P n n go
to infinity and this is fixed if you
would allow this to depend on P then you
would have ah Oh got it
okay then yes you have something here
that depends on s max or something like
that yeah but that's why I want it yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yes in the very
simulation - you have to make some
choices about how far the level so yes I
took okay so excellent a it turns out
that in simulations once you satisfy
this the results are very weakly
dependent on alpha any alpha would do
I'm removing the the before I do the
threshold thing I'm I'm removing this
part okay and in arson empirically in r0
both theoretically but those completely
in L simulations there's no dependence
and out are very weak dependence so so
if you pick alpha B no you should pick
alpha to be at least as loud okay
theoretically you would want it at least
all this you don't know this so just
take alpha to be larger than then
yeah this is actually what we did in the
simulations the thresholding we used
what value for special wine you showed
us your curse uh Wow opening in the
paper but some constant that's creative
love PR in doing that in a data-driven
manner is there's an open question yeah
last question I just wanted to share
what I mean typically when you're a
fixed penalty let's say for example I
assume things like that you get bites
the reason you don't here is because the
thing is is in very scale right right
bringing in the output or the Alpha I
you have a penalty yeah I'm not sure I'm
following your question well I mean it's
just right it's a check on that why is
it that you do not have bias in your
estimation ah it's because a function of
alpha yes I'm removing the the part on
alpha
yes sorry by scale myself by subtracting
the aisle five
that's the estimate all and I I'm doing
this part okay okay thank you very much
[Applause]